hi there
i'm arya and we're here to spend a night
with the juggalos
come on in we go right out in here do
you have your pass uh
no okay
for those unaware juggalos are fans of
the hip hop duo insane clown
posse and they're a passionate community
known for having their own unique
culture
from wearing face paint to spraying the
soft drink fago at concerts
juggalos have often been met with
ridicule with the fbi even going as far
as to controversially classify them
as a gang so to try and separate fact
from fiction
i decided to spend the night at an icp
concert
to experience first hand what it means
to be
a juggalo all right what is this tattoo
symbol hatchet man
that just means that we were down with
the clown what does it mean to be down
with the clown
to be down with the clown well for one
we're not a gang don't matter if you're
black white yellow purple
it don't matter you find love from what
i understand there is
juggalo slang if you're a juggalo and
they see you walking and you've got some
of the
the the material on you'll get a whoop
whoop
and that's a sign of respect let's say
i'm wearing some icp merch okay that's
the simulated situation so i'm walking
won't family and that's all in it right
and that's all we do
after i eventually find my press pass
i'm able to meet up with the paulus
brothers
who are vip ticket holders for tonight's
show is it too late to paint your face
you got to go find somebody there's
always somebody with face paint it's
just not the same without the face mate
despite being decades-long fans of icp
tonight will mark the very first time
they're actually able to meet the duo
and spray faga with them on stage it's
one of my life's ambitions and my life
dream
like after the first show i was like i'm
never going to be a dope rapper but one
day i will be up there i will be
throwing soda
i will be you know just doing that i
want to do that
and that stayed with me for you know the
past 15
20 years you guys are genuinely very
very friendly people
i mean which is we try to be yeah it
gets fascinating because you know if i
was walking down the street and you guys
were walking with his face
yeah i mean because we're wearing corpse
paint we look like [ __ ] weirdos but i
mean
yeah i would avoid you too but anybody
who's going to a show
obviously looks like a weirdo we're just
a little bit more pronounced in that
fact
the people that are there for the music
and there for the right reason
those are the people that i call family
those are my juggalos those are my
people so
it's you know a couple bad apples
spoiled a whole bunch unfortunately but
i think you could say that's the case
for any community or or culture that
could be for anybody from
you know the furries to the to the
larpers yeah to michael buble fans
they're the worst man they got ships
because they don't check the old lady's
purses some of the songs have a little
bit of weird racy content
but at the end of the day it does have a
positive message
you just have to kind of get through the
whole thing but going through the entire
journey
is half of what made being a juggalo fun
i then chat with tim who was also
moments away from
meeting icp for the first time how
excited are you
um less excited more nervous
icp kind of preaches like if you're
bullied if your life
sucks you know all that stuff icp comes
out with their music and they're like
hey our life sucks too
so let's suck lives together and they
have a song
simple and blunt there's a line
specifically that says
let us do the killing for you you'll be
all right and it's not like actual
killing it's more like a metaphor like
hey
let us be angry let us you know
do all that bad stuff you'll be fine
before the vip meet and greet begins i'm
actually able to sit down with insane
clown posse themselves
to learn more about this massive
community they've built over the years
what do you say to somebody that comes
up to you and says hey man
i was going to kill myself but your
music saved my life
and they take their shirt off and their
whole back is a tattoo of your face
you know what i'm saying how do you say
thank you to that you know hey
thanks guy that don't cover it believe
it or not they look us in the face
and say you saved my life your music
saved my life you know
that type of appreciation from them for
us
for us doing something we love doing and
we would
can do anything to be able to do this
and then to be appreciated like that for
it
it's almost unfathomable you couldn't
ask for a better fan base or better
people in the world you know saying
people from the outside like to look in
make fun of them call them white trash
grown pieces uneducated all that
couldn't be further from the truth you
know saying it's the most warmest
openness
there's from doctors to homeless people
you know what i'm saying the whole
spectrum
just like life juggalos cover the whole
a to z what should i be ready for
tonight
we always tell somebody never seen us
before we're like hey man i'm sorry to
tell you this
we're gonna apologize right now because
you're going to see somebody else we're
[ __ ]
up for you
like us ever again michael buble is
ruined for me now everybody michael
whatever his name is thank you guys so
much i'm looking forward to it
thank you my man thank you we have a
group hug
uh yeah hell yeah i mean yeah
i wish he wasn't here so i could get
your full arms
you doing brother doing well how are you
guys good man i'm doing a lot better now
what was that like uh no words it's 22
years in the making
you look like a doctor or something no
close i work with the handicapped
community actually see
i'm just rambling no words it's awesome
i'm just happy
i'm happy yeah no words i'm so geeked
right now
thank you guys for a second yeah it was
probably 40 more embarrassing than i
thought it was gonna be
obviously jay and shaggy are cool as
[ __ ] and they made it special
just for me as an awkward total neck
beard weirdo walking up to them like
what's up bro and they made they made it
cool they made it they made it
ugh i got no words i literally cannot
describe
how geeked out i am about meeting the
clowns and shaking their hands
oh my god and now you get to watch them
perform
but before the concert starts there's
one final thing that i need to take care
of
coming into tonight i had no idea
what to expect but that's the thing
about misconceptions isn't it
because in general we often have a
tendency to allow the negative to
overshadow all the good
we see these face painted people
listening to this intense
dark music and we allow ourselves to
forget that these are just regular
people that have found
something that makes them happy at the
end of the day
we all just want to feel like we belong
somewhere
and that's what juggalos have found in
each other they come from all walks of
life yet have been brought together
through the music
and there's something wonderful about
that
you'll often hear juggalos refer to
themselves as a family
and tonight i genuinely felt like i was
one of them
so whoop whoop cause i'm down with the
clown
i just turned 40 two days ago on march
20th happy belated birthday thank you
very much
happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear dennis